[Music]
[Applause]
how you doing is please
uh my name is John tiple do you hear me
good I am the Sports Coordinator St Nur
I've been a commissioner and a resident
of Midland Beach for 51 years so I have
the
best I also own a
few my my question
is really towards the um getting getting
the approval from the
building commission normally they do
impact studies if you notice in this
community there are four schools
four uh new nor high school is2 38 St
mar
mar most of those kids who go to those
schools
walk what I'm concerned about is on
Friday uh the number of Cs that into
this community which were over saturated
today if you look at Avenue starting at
2:30 the amount of traffic coming up at
is is very very hi my question comes
down to is what are the programs one of
the time slots and has building
department did an impact study on the
community nothing do religion as you
indicated a number of your kids playing
our program and we love having can I
answer that
question I'm asking impct no no I'm
asking you about they their schedule for
the use of the building it is not just
Friday afternoon 1 to 2 my question is
how long a period of time and you must
have done your analysis on what your
schedule is going to be because you
already have programs another another Mo
my question is how often are you going
to be using that why is a number of
people who know something you can't tell
because you wouldn't buy the building if
you couldn't tell I want to know exactly
want impact you're going to have in a
way of both foot traffic as well as
Squad traffic and don't tell me
somebody's going to walk six blocks cuz
it's really seven cuz you got to go into
the field so that's another block all
right and it closes at dust so again my
question comes down to
how will use the building and I ask you
to be as detailed as possible don't give
mean don't give
[Music]
me prayers in the those prayers the
numers attending between 15 to 20 people
every and in the morning I six seven
people in the afternoon prayer will be 6
to 7 at no at the uh sunset time by 9:00
at night that's the number you might
have 20 to 25 people that's in the
regular way as far as the programs the
programs will be after the school time
will start 4: to 6 every day plus the
weekend will be from 9 to 6:00 on the
weekends Friday will be the player will
be 1 to two the issue of parking as I
said either we can ask the community how
many people will attend Friday prayer
whatever the building allow us if it's
100 people 100 people if it's 150
150 and if the paring issue as I said
either to get a
[Music]
sh John as far as the the impact I spoke
to Tom Co Deputy B Commissioner of DT I
said to him considering that we are the
Gateway from the Southshore to the
bridge anyway and we can't get any
traffic enforcement on gry Avenue to
begin with isn't this going to call for
a traffic study traffic impact study he
said no this does not call this does not
fall under a traffic impact study they
only do traffic impact studies for large
projects which would be the widening of
Richmond uh Richmond Hill Road stuff
like that I asked him but this is going
to have a very big impact in the
community says it does not call for it
it's one building okay my comment to
that is when we had the first Dead child
wife
Paul and I'm not trying to take you guys
long what I'm trying to understand is we
have a serious problem in this community
as I said we've got four schools within
a
mile it's not four schools okay 20 mil
here
whatever it's going to be very
critical that we make sure that this K
are safe the only time we get anything
done in this community is when somebody
dies and they put up a lot of flowers
and get light that you cannot put up
with that and I'm sorry to say I'm going
to fight you I have to
[Applause]
[Music]
my question is on Su to 6 what do I do
when I have basketball games and I don't
have any part I've got a problem and
I've got to worry about my community
kids I'm sorry to say for your prayer
[Music]
[Applause]
service said no was a good fight
R
okay I'm saying everybody
Itali big the people say all Italian
Mafia are big are they
[Music]
not I welcome my
AR know the bigot tree workers the power
workers of the world unit
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
minut okay we heard to
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
know
[Music]
[Applause]
not all Italian mafia not all Italian a
mafia to the world
we I want to exess tonight that this is
not what we here for okay we need to act
Civ anybody that gets like PR
all right can you he all right next
question you got to move up to
[Music]
the in any event was born in 1950 down
1952 a lot of you remember we got
flooded it was the great flood of M
Beach I lost my lost my family lost
their home they lost their home my
godfather the firefighter lost the scate
we were fortunate enough to be placed in
a housing F that where I I would know
have to go to 8 years to St Mar man two
buses in two buses back I had Seven
Sisters the only reason Seven Sisters of
the presentation and the only reason I
had seven was I had Sister Mary for 2
years and I was sitting in the classroom
eighth grade classroom on this rounds
for this Olympia Activity Center was
built in November 1963 for the first
time in 8 years I saw a sister of the
presentation C when President Kenny was
assassinated in that class 52 kids Run
by One n we change gles or anything else
my parents question my parents it will
come at the end my parents before like L
the F it was called The Pledge we took a
pledge to build that contct okay to us
I'm not getting the Rel I'm not getting
Poli was a very special place one thing
we can say the sist of the presentation
you could never ever pull the W over
their AR they never ever made a back
door deal okay we know that who grew up
and were associated the Sy of
presentation now I the Marine right
in
1970 I was part of a special na Ren War
operation the
group dup of the terrorist organization
it became known black sep our job took
two days to get the special Unit 13
Marines onto USS
Independence if the event happened four
cheets were hijack four cheets were
hijack some of them went to Airfield
join the idea was Americans were
involved United Kingdoms people were
involved and other people if they were
going to keep the hostages we were going
in let them go and blew up the Chets on
September
11th 2001 security manager to the World
Trade Cent even down I was trapped in
the building I was saved by the
f i
le5 to suffer from Little which phly
know and I was fortunate enough they
have a little trans they didn't know
what was it what I was told it was The
Toxic
system 31 years later I experienced
terrorism again this time literally
first what now my question man I told
you come at the end you don't have stop
and I fully respect M be the parish and
I went the first your father has and
introduced as they had said previously
you could never pull the wall over the
presentation
my question is I ask this stre CH in
front of this audience if you see
something if you hear something if you
suspect something will you notify the
proper American father
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely yes that was my question and
thank you very
my name
is your position was
that position well if it is perhaps you
should
be I tell
why I was handing this when I walked in
actually I some other people and this is
basically your propaganda what what you
left out with some facts facts stuff
thing and why you should possibly be on
that
Bo L the executive director R supported
three individuals there's many more I'll
be brief the guy Abu Ali arrested for to
kill George Bush your booss
suppor
Al convicted of urging followers to kill
Americans in Afghanistan and Pakistan
your boy
supported your boy
supported he's convicted
also for sponsoring terrorism the last
individual that I mentioned your Great
America Mr Spencer by calling him a ring
the other individual
call now what you left out of those guys
you you conveniently included citations
from TOS VAR politicians and I
appreciate that for hold responsible we
have conversations course I'll
have okay it's very simple now your not
about you spoke about many good things
your organization does and probably does
very well things good things we have
convicted members of organized gangs in
prison at people before they write
Children books that's State we're not
interested in propaganda we're interest
[Applause]
[Music]
question is where where is and does he
support no can I ask you a question with
me do you believe in the legal system of
the US yes I do okay we do too thank you
you the
[Applause]
[Music]
question has
given he's not my boss by the way he's
he's the director of the of the mass
Freedom which is a civil rights movement
M Bray may have uh worked in some of the
of the Civil I mean rights cases that
does not necessarily mean that you
endorse if those people found to be
guilty they are
guilty me let me ask your question M
gray is a civil rights activist he has
given he has
given he has given he has given sat of
advance
[Music]
statement has given the
ADV a statement on position Fromm he
proun all form ofis this is the answer
for question next
question
[Music]
question us
ofation has done they help
thousand helping
my question is are you going to make
thousands of people of this community
Happy
[Music]
[Applause]
by thank you very much that's your
opinion our opinion
[Applause]
no list of things you do people I would
like say something in here you know what
if you look at the
[Music]
Bible as the man so is what we need to
know what we need to do is think
positively instead of thinking negativ
so if you think
negative we not
[Applause]
[Music]
next
question next question yeah my name is
Lori and I have a question regarding BR
okay first of all I'm told that Islam is
a religion of Peace a peaceful religion
but I'm curious as to whether or not the
Quran says that to fight the infidels to
kill all infidels are we the Americans
the westerners the
[Music]
[Applause]
infidels it doesn't sound very peaceful
to me when it says kill thank you the
answer no you are not going who is okay
the all the verses again this goes okay
you asking questions that requires an
intellectual discussion so I would
really appreciate the
people I'll sit down any time the Quran
all all the verses in the Quran that
talks about fighting with
killing are verses that are red in very
specific incident at particular
circumstances during the time of war in
the battlefield talking taking those
vers out of cont and making a general
move out of them WR and this is the
misting that I Spen about in the Quran
and by the way those who misquote those
verses they pick and choose they they
pick and choose they forget for example
what God revealed who are the infidels
that's my question who who does the
Quran consider the Infidel that that
that in in Islam a person who was given
the message clearly with no
misconception and continues to re
not only that and fight and prosecute
and torture Muslims this is what the
Quran means by the word who rejects
Muslim no I said not I said not only
reject reject fight prute and torture
Muslims this is what is considered in
the Quran a disbeliever or an empty
[Music]
that's of mus religion
next
question United States is made up
several
nationalities I'm a
res the United States has made up of all
different colors all different all
different religions all different
nationalities as Muslims I'd like to
know how you feel about Christians how
you feel about Jews how you feel about
women how you feel about
children is married with chrans and
Jews that's one of my questions
and would you like your
[Music]
children Nation
background and so on as far as the
Christians are
concerned we have here a priest an our
priest with us in here right here and I
would like to ask him later on to come
to the podium also and say somewh as far
as the the Jewish the Jewish people yes
we have friends we deal with the Jewish
people we have no problem with that
talking
about talking talking about our children
I don't think that we have the right to
make our children after 18 years choose
whatever they want to do not what I ask
you I ask
feel our children Christian or Jews they
want to be Christian or Jews or they
would like to get
married Mar if they want to get married
to a Christian or Jew we don't have any
problem you Christian and the Jews are
the people of the book in the Quran
[Applause]
are
they Muslims are allowed to they allowed
to the
chur okay question and is well we only
get how many questions do you
have minutes everybody else got around 3
minutes isn't one of the pillars of Isam
to commit Jihad against the infidel
and isn't it written in the Quran that
that it's okay to deceive the Infidel in
order to
[Music]
conqu
of the five cols of his is to testify
that there is no God but Allah and again
Allah is the Arabic Bo of God that is
used by Arab chrans of two is to
establish prayer three is to give
charity which is called zakat 2.5% of
your wealth and your money to pass the
month of Ramadan and to perform
pilgrimage once a lifetime those are the
five pillars of Islam another pillar of
Islam answering your question
Jihad is the right of a Nation to fight
back for a
selfdefense when they are oppressed or
occupied or tortured by others so
wouldn't that put the us as infidels
because we're fighting Muslims in Iraq
and Afghanistan consider the answer is
no the answer is no if I do consider the
us as any I would have not been here
raising my five children here we
actually believe we actually we do
believe I do person and and represent M
here and other Islamic organization
believe that the principles upon which
America has built are much closer to
Islam than the practices of many Muslim
countries as we speak at